in 1918 there was this huge Navy ship  that was carrying 300 men he was headed  to Baltimore and it went right through  this stretch of water called the Bermuda  Triangle you've maybe heard of it before  but the ship never arrived to Baltimore  despite being able to the ship never  sent out an SOS distress call no wreck  was ever found 300 men gone the Navy  literally came out and said that this  disappearance was the most baffling  mysteries in the annals of the Navy  that's an official quote this is just  one of over 70 mysterious disappearances  hundreds of people vanished in this one  little stretch of water I wanted to know  what was going on here so I did a big  deep dive into the Bermuda Triangle and  what I learned was kind of surprising go  ahead and check it out on my channel